hello
my name is samson soh and today
i will be talking about the sensitivity
analysis
of the maximum matching problem this is
joint work
with yoichi yoshida
sensitivity is a measure of how much a
discrete algorithm changes
when the input changes for example
for a deterministic graph algorithm a on
a graph g
that has n vertices the average
sensitivity of the algorithm
is defined as the expected value
of the number of edges in the symmetric
difference
between the output of the algorithm a
on the input g compared to the output of
the algorithm a
on the input g minus e where the
expectation is taken over all
edges e in the edge set of g
so this definition is a mouthful and
maybe it would be
better illustrated with an example
so let's consider the case where the
algorithm a is the greedy algorithm
that outputs a maximal matching on a
graph with six nodes
and suppose that this graph has the edge
set
that is appears on the left side of the
screen
well the greedy algorithm is with
respect to some ordering of the edges
so let's suppose that the edge set has
the following ordering
suppose that we first see the horizontal
black edge on the right side
and since it's the first edge that
appears then the greedy algorithm adds
it to the maximum matching
next let's suppose we see the falling
black diagonal edge
since it's already incident to an edge
in the matching the blue edge
then the black diagonal edge will not be
added to the maximal matching
similarly the greedy algorithm does not
add the third diagonal edge
to the maximum matching
the fourth edge is not added to matching
and so forth
now when the last edge appears it is not
incident to any
edges that's already in the matching and
thus it's already added
it's thus it's also added to the
matching
so for this graph and the ordering that
we showed previously
the maximum matching returned by the
greedy algorithm
will be the two blue edges on the right
now let's suppose that we have the same
graph but the first edge
the horizontal black edge is removed and
let's suppose
the ordering of the remaining edges
remains the same
now the greedy algorithm will add the
first diagonal edge
and also add the first the second
diagonal edge to the maximum matching
the next two edges will not be added to
the matching but the final edge
will be added to the matching as well
thus in the first case the maximum
matching returned by degree algorithm
is the two horizontal blue lines
whereas in the second example the
maximum matching returned by the greedy
algorithm
is the graph that is the lower right
now the symmetric difference between
these two graphs
is indicated by the edges in red
thus the symmetric difference has
carnality 3.
now the average sensitivity for the
greedy algorithm
repeats this analysis averaged
over all edges e that's in the graph
again the sensitivity is a measure of
how much a discrete algorithm changes
when the input changes but this
definition that we
described previously is for a
deterministic algorithm
for a randomized algorithm the average
sensitivity is defined
as the expectation of the earth movement
distance
between the output of the algorithm a
and the input g versus the output of the
algorithm a on the input g minus e
and we consider this quantity an
expectation over all
edges e in the ad set of g
this definition is well motivated by a
number of
applications and the first one we'll
consider
is a situation in which we have number
of clients
that demand service from a number of
servers on the left
suppose that we have some possible
routes that connect the
servers to the clients and we want to
form a matching
to give as many clients service as
possible
let me choose some matching on this
underlying network
and this matching is indicated by the
edges in blue
but now suppose that another edge
arrives
this is indicated by the horizontal
black edge at the top
we still want to provide service to as
many customers as possible
so we choose a new maximal matching
in this case we choose the horizontal
blue edges
but the symmetric difference between the
first matching and the second matching
is actually the entire network and thus
if we need to build some
infrastructure to support the connection
between the clients and the servers
then we have to rebuild this
infrastructure completely
when we obtain a new edge
thus it is advantageous to consider an
algorithm
that has low sensitivity meaning
that when a new edge arrives or an old
edge
is deleted that the infrastructure
needed
to maintain the matching between the
server and the clients is minimalized
average sensitivity for graph algorithms
was first considered by mirai
and yoshida for the quantity centrality
they analyzed how much quantities such
as centralities for
page rank betweenness and charity and so
forth
changed when an edge in the network
was deleted or added
here sinchad is a quantity that roughly
measures how important
a vertex is in the underlying network
subsequently varmint yoshida considered
the adversary
for a number of graph algorithms that
output edge and vertex sets
they considered the problems of minimum
spanning forest global minimum cut
maximum matching vertex cover and so
forth
yoshida also considered the average
sensitivity for spectral
uh clustering
namely they gave a number of algorithms
with
a spectral with sensitivity that depends
on the eigenvalues
of the
in this work we introduce the definition
of worst case sensitivity
rather than average case sensitivity
whereas the average sensitivity is
defined
with respect to the expectation of the
earth movement distance
the worst case sense to be is defined
with respect to the maximum
[Music]
between the output of the algorithm a
on g and g minus e across all
edges e and the underlying edge set
we first give a one plus epsilon
approximation to the maximum matching
problem with worst case
edge sensitivity of one where here we
suppress all dependencies on
epsilon we'll also talk about a
deterministic algorithm
for maximal matching with worst cases to
be delta to the x
where x is this quantity here and delta
is an upper bound on the degree of
the vertices in the underlying graph
so we'll first talk about the one plus
epsilon approximation algorithm
and notice that our result improves upon
a result of
pharma and yoshida that give
a one plus epsilon approximation
to the maximum matching but has average
sensitivity
in this quantity as follows namely
up here is the number of edges in the
maximum matching and it can be as large
as n
so they give an algorithm with average
sensitivity roughly n over epsilon cubed
and this is average sensitivity whereas
we give an algorithm that gives a
one plus epsilon approximation but has
worst case since v
o of one
so not only do we improve upon the
sensitivity but this is the average
sensitivity versus the worst case
sensitivity
now this can be difficult because the
previous example illustrates that the
greedy algorithm can have sensitivity
omega n
for maximal matching recall that just by
adding a single edge
we can force the maximal matching by the
greedy algorithm to entirely change
so that the sensitivity the symmetric
difference is actually
the set of all edges in the graph
fortunately we first show that for
randomized greedy
we can have a analysis that shows a much
lower sensitivity
so in the randomized greedy what we'll
do is first
randomly choose a permutation of the
edges in the graph
and then we'll run the greedy algorithm
on this permutation of the order
the idea is that the expected deleted or
edited edge
should appear roughly halfway through
the ordering of the edges
and this seems kind of bad because if it
only appears halfway through
the ordering then maybe we'll still have
sensitivity on mega end
but the intuition is that most of the
edges in the matching
either occur early in the ordering if
the underlying graph is dense
or the added or deleted edge does not
affect many other edges in the matching
if it's a sparse graph
formally if we let pi of e for an edge e
be the rank in the underlying ordering
that we choose
then we define i sub pi of e to be the
neighbors of e
with smaller rank than e
now it's clear that we have an invariant
that
shows that if e is in the maximum
matching
then uh it can only be the case if and
only
that no edges of i sub pi of e are in
the matching
now we want to consider the set s of
edges that must be modified to maintain
the variant
if an edge e is moved to the beginning
of pi
so this is our sensitivity analysis
where we show that e
is um added or deleted
but actually we show that we can
consider the case where e is moved to
the beginning of the permutation
now unless pi of e
is equal to the minimum of pi of s
then no edges need to be modified
this is not obvious but it can be shown
with a bit of work
it can also be shown that pi of e is
equal to the minimum of pi of s with
probability one
over the size of s and thus the expected
number of modified edges
is o of one
so this analysis is a bit evolved but
similar ideas were previously used
to show an algorithm for maxim mole
independent set
in the dynamic distributed setting by
sensor hill at all
so now we have a toy sub routine that
shows that the randomized greedy for
maximal matchings with worst case
infinity
of one can be used as initial
procedure and our goal is to go from
maximal matching
to one plus epsilon approximation
algorithm for maximum matching
one possible approach that also extends
from a maximal matching to a
maximum matching approximation algorithm
is the multi-pass streaming algorithm of
mcgregor
the streaming algorithm mcgregor uses a
layered
creates a graph with l plus one layers
that simultaneously sample a large
number of augmenting paths of length
l for example
consider the left graph that has a
maximum matching
m with two edges in an augmenting path
of length three
then the corresponding layered graph if
we are only interested
in augmenting paths of three will have
four layers
the first and last layer will have
vertices corresponding to each vertex
in the graph on the left and the middle
layers
will all have vertices corresponding to
the edges in the underlying graph
thus we see that 1 2 is an edge in the
graph on the left
and the vertex corresponding to 1 2
appears in both the layer 1 l1
and l2 on the right
now the layered graph randomly chooses
edges
between vertices
when there are edges present in the
corresponding graph on the left
this induces a number of augmenting
paths and thus we can sample a large
number of augmenting paths from this
layered graph
now we'll terminate this procedure in
roughly one over epsilon iterations so
that we have
all augmenting paths
of length 1 length 2 and then 3 all the
way to length 1 over epsilon
we'll sample a number of augmenting
paths from each of
these lengths
and thus we've achieved augmenting paths
of length up to one over epsilon and
this is enough to get a one plus epsilon
approximation algorithm
for maximum matching
now we'll do this roughly k times and
thus will get the
roughly k augmenting paths
and k here is some quantity that's
independent of n
it's only dependent on epsilon
now we do this k times and it can be
shown that in the first
step our sensitivity is at most three
in the second iteration these three
edges can further affect at most
three times three edges which is nine
and arguing inductively we see that the
worst case in city
is at most three to the k which is still
order 1
when we suppress dependencies on epsilon
moreover our runtime is roughly n plus m
where n is number of vertices and m is
number of edges times k
so this is our linear time algorithm
that gives a1 plus epsilon approximation
to the maximum matching problem
and has worst case edge sensitivity 01.
next we'll talk about a deterministic
outcome for maximum matching with worst
case sensitivity delta to the x
where x is the quantity here
delta is the largest degree of a vertex
in the graph
our deterministic algorithm uses two
ingredients
the first ingredient is a deterministic
local computation algorithm by colin
michigan
that produces six to the delta coloring
of a graph with degree delta
the lca uses delta
times log star and queries
and has the property that the
lca only queries vertices within
distance log star
n so to get the coloring of a node
the lca will look at the colorings
of adjacent nodes then i'll look at
nodes that are adjacent to the adjacent
nodes and so forth but only query
vertices are within distance log star
n at a high level the algorithm
partitions the graph
into forests and assigns each vertex a
color based on the least significant bit
that differs between the node id and the
parent id
the second ingredient that our
deterministic algorithm will use
is a framework by parness and ron that
simulates local distributed algorithms
using deterministic lcas with
delta to oc probes where c is the number
of colors that we use
the framework iterates through colors
and adds each edge to a maximum matching
if no adjacent edge is already in the
matching
one can think of this algorithm as a
greedy algorithm where you first
produce a maximum matching with respect
to the greedy paradigm
but then we iterate through the colors
and repeat this paradigm
on the pre-built maxwell matching at
each
the key property we'll use from this
framework is that only queries vertices
within distance
6 to the delta
so combining these facts we have a
deterministic lca that queries vertices
within distance
log star n in a framework that queries
vertices within distance
6 to the
and by considering a tree analysis one
can show that the sensitivity is at most
uh delta to this quantity six to the
delta plus log star
n
this is because this is the number of
queries in the lca that can be affected
by a single deletion or addition
we can show this by starting at the root
of a tree and proceeding downwards
so this gives boasts both our one plus
epsilon approximation
to the maximum matching problem and our
deterministic algorithm for maximal
matching
we also show in the paper that any
deterministic algorithm
that gives a constant factor
approximation for the max matching
problem
has worst case edge sensitivity omega
log star n
we show this using ramsey theory and
also note that
our worst case egg sensitivity also
applies when both vertices
and edges are deleted from the graph
we also give a theorem that shows that
any graph
with edges bounded by w which is some
quantity that is polynomial n
we can find an algorithm that outputs a
4 alpha approximation
to the maximum weighted matching problem
where a
alpha is a trade-off parameter
for alpha equals two the algorithm has
weighted sensitivity w log
n and normalized weighted sensitivity
log n
for alpha larger than two the outcome
has weighted since d o
w and normalized since weighted
sensitivity of one
here weighted since three is a natural
generalization of adsensitivity that we
introduce in the paper
because our paper is the first to
consider worst case sensitivity
we believe there are a number of
interesting feature directions that we
can study
already there has been analysis of worst
case sensitivity for monotone to modular
maximization by mikmion
we can also look at worst case
normalized weighted sensitivity for
other graph problems
another interesting question is whether
there exists constant factor
approximation algorithms
for maximum weight and matching with low
worst case sensitivity
finally we can consider whether there
exists one plus epsilon approximation
algorithms for maximum weighted
matchings
with low worst case normalized weighted
sensitivity
for full details refer to the paper and
thank you for listening to our
presentation
you